my question has to do a little bit with
Jordan Peterson mm-hmm hysteria with you
know Canada's bills c16 yes with the
compelled speech law right I just want
to know do you think that is there's
anything to worry about in America as
far as compelled speech goes government
overreach yes so I think that I think
that anti-discrimination laws are going
to be used as an excuse to crack down on
religious institutions and people who
disagree so the way this will happen
because that's what Bill c16 is it's an
anti-discrimination law the idea is that
you are discriminating against people if
you do not use the proper pronoun right
this already exists by the way I believe
in New York City the New York City Human
Rights Commission passed an ordinance
that will find restaurants like $250,000
if they do not if they do not address a
patron by the pronoun that person wishes
to be addressed by I don't know how that
stands up to the First Amendment I
really don't but that also requires in
Supreme Court that's willing to
implement the First Amendment and so
that depends a lot on whether justice
kennedy has had a bowel movement that
day it's impossible to predict whether
Justice Kennedy is going to go one way
or another on any particular on any
particular issue I do see this happening
in California now there was already an
attempt to strip the Boy Scouts of their
501c3 status in the state of California
because the Boy Scouts weren't allowing
gays Scout masters you could certainly
see something very similar happening if
they refused to address people by
particular pronouns or if a church or
synagogue refuses to perform a same-sex
wedding they can say okay well you have
a non-profit status but you're violating
our view of what should happen with
regard to marriage the state now
recognizes marriages between men and men
and women and women so we're going to
remove that status from you I think
we're moving pretty quickly in that
direction that's where the left clearly
wants to go now the only question is
what are the constitutional barriers
we'll be strong enough to prevent it
again I think that it depends I think
it's up to us I don't rely on the
supreme court to protect the
Constitution because it historically has
done a pretty poor job of it